do not move
[Music]
edge of your feet you see him good his
elbow i can see him good
matt
use your left hand and unlock the door
only your left hand
put your hands back on your head
do not move
yes sir
stick both your hands out this way matt
both of them scream
just listen to what you're being told
all right
take that undo your uh
seat belt all right
when you pull them off
all right
keep your hands right
coming off
you got anything on you at all right
straight out here we're going to work
come on
step straight is your car in drip park
all right step on now man
good guy all right we're going to walk
over here towards the ground all right
come together
can you come this way
you ready to watch that trunk
coming up
yep
you have a floor latch in the driver's
side
nah nothing like this weight defense
that's it
[Applause]
damn
good
coming up on your left come up
matt
use your left hand and unlock the door
only your left hand
put your hands back on your head
all right
take that and undo your uh
seat belt
[Music]
all
make a like a blade with your hand there
i'm right here
we got a code three on our suspect
[Applause]
walk back towards the driver's side
my wallet's in my left pocket
if you got a cell phone or anything you
want another car oh yeah it might still
fall in that car it's in the car we're
at i think
you want it yeah
when he sits down i did it you already
gotta
[Applause]
thank you
emily noble went missing in may 2020 her
body was then found four months later
hanging from a tree but experts believe
her body was staged to look like a
suicide
do not move
her husband matthew moore has been
charged with her murder and is set to
stand trial was it suicide or was it
murder tune into the law crime network
for gavel to gavel coverage
[Music]
you